that's what Landry says land use really
is the confluence of all of that it's
really the the embodiment of how society
interacts with the environment so it has
economic aspects cultural aspects the
ecological aspects the physical aspects
climate and it's just where all of those
issues come together and that's what
attracts me to that to that issue well
right now there's a movement to to
incorporate these ecosystem services to
jargon of a word into into the market so
that the payment for ecosystem services
landowners get actual economic benefit
out of managing the landscape in ways
that are congruent with maintaining
ecosystem services whether that's
protecting a watershed or conservation
of biodiversity so there's a the
movement now is to build those aspects
into the economic decisions that people
make about how they manage the land so
we'll see how that goes but it's a very
exciting and promising movement right
now well there's nothing more
contentious than the management of
forest areas is full of corruption and
large areas that are very difficult to
to enforce so that is a big issue in
this current discussion about the
development of policies to reduce
deforestation there's a lot of potential
money to be made out of that and there
are a lot of actors and who
it's and who loses out and who really
owns the carbon in the forest is a big
big big question and then dessert